sonic is back with a new friend and a
new foe in sonic the hedgehog 2. and a
familiar voice is bringing the blue
blur's new friend tails to life on the
big screen here's everything else you
need to know before you see sonic the
hedgehog 2.
let's do this even after it was almost
derailed by a set of eerily
human-looking teeth the film adaptation
of sega's beloved mascot was a hit both
with fans of the games and at the box
office earning nearly 320 million
dollars worldwide although critics felt
there was some room for improvement the
zippy design of sonic himself and the
likable cast of human characters were
enough to have the film declared the
rare successful video game adaptation
just three months after the release of
the first movie variety confirmed that
sonic the hedgehog 2 was officially on
the way with director jeff fowler and
screenwriters pat casey and josh miller
all returning in the first film we're
introduced to sonic an alien hedgehog
who uses a dimension bending ring to
travel to earth once there he's pursued
by the evil dr robotnik who wants to
harness sonic's supersonic speed for use
in his robotics experiments sonic teams
up with sheriff tom and his wife maddie
in order to evade dr robotnik's
increasingly menacing attempts to
capture the hedgehog sonic the hedgehog
was enjoyable and did justice to the
games but it also left lots of room to
go bigger and better with another
installment now that we know one is on
the way let's dig into the details of
what we know about the release date cast
and plot of the upcoming sonic the
hedgehog 2. when paramount made the
announcement about the sequel it was
just that news and not much else however
in late july 2020 the studio revealed
the official release date for sonic the
hedgehog 2. ben schwartz who voices the
speedy little hedgehog posted to his
twitter account a video of himself
confirming the news the video simply
featured sorts strolling beside massive
promotional posters for sonic the
hedgehog while awkwardly explaining what
he was seeing the caption of the video
is where the actor made things crystal
clear sonic 2 is officially coming to
theaters april 8 2022 one of the biggest
drinks of the first sonic the hedgehog
was its cast bin schwartz best known for
parks and recreation and the after party
and an avowed fan of the original sonic
games gave an energetic vocal
performance as the titular hedgehog jim
carrey was delightfully unhinged as the
villainous doctor robotnik while james
marsden and tikka sumter provided the
right balance of humor and heart as
sonic's unassuming human allies all four
actors will reprise their roles in sonic
the hedgehog 2. colleen o'shaughnessy
who voiced tales in the sonic games
performed the character's dialogue in a
brief post-credits sequence that sets up
tails to be a much more prominent part
of the next film and o'shaughnessy will
return there are two new big names in
the cast of sonic the hedgehog 2. in
june 2021 shimar moore well known for
his work on cbs procedurals criminal
minds and swat posted to instagram a
picture of himself on the sonic 2 set
with the other primary members of the
human cast he announced his casting but
didn't reveal any details about his
character however moore briefly appears
in a scene in the third sonic the
hedgehog 2 trailer in august 2021
variety reported that emmy and
oscar-nominated superstar idris elba had
joined sonic the hedgehog 2 as the voice
of knuckles a sonic adversary turned
ally in the 90's sega games during the
2021 game awards sonic the hedgehog 2
voice actor ben schwartz introduced the
first trailer for the film with a second
teaser arriving in time for the 2022
super bowl both clips revealed a few
details about the plot of the highly
anticipated sequel after sonic blasted
away dr robotnik to a mushroom planet in
the first film he was determined to
escape his prison and return to earth as
revealed in the third trailer which hit
the internet on march 14th dr robotnik
returns to wreak more havoc and he's in
possession of a giant green emerald
which he proclaims to be the source of
ultimate power sonic after crashing
through a ring portal on a pile of snow
rudely interrupting a hawaiian
destination wedding announces his
intention to stop his persistent nemesis
or otherwise the world is doomed neither
side is alone in their quest this time
dr robotnik has brought along the
destructive and nefarious in kidna
knuckles while sonic has tails fighting
in his corner overall the sonic sequel
looks like it has much more in common
with the games that inspired the movie
with familiar faces on a new adventure
hopefully everyone will love
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]